and now to tonight's daily download sir
the police are here please
detective can we talk about this
I'm gonna pay you for your time
stop
it's not a cop this is what my son does
he plays these games let the greed begin
because the trailer for sharper with
Julianne Moore is here and everyone is
competing for riches and power what are
you doing here just wanted to say hi
good time all right cool see you around
I always assumed my son would inherit
all this he doesn't have the fortitude
he's weak
foreign
Jeremy Leonard is still recovering after
undergoing surgery to address blunt
chest trauma and Orthopedic injuries due
to a terrifying accident involving a
snowplow but Morgan caught up with
renner's mayor of Kingstown co-star Hugh
Dylan who shared an update on the
actor's progress I pick up my phone in
areas
cracking jokes and I was just like oh my
God and then I was relieved because you
know this guy is getting up and he is a
fighter and to be on the phone what he's
doing is making me feel better you know
because he's just I can't even you know
some of his jokes are a little profane
so I can't share them today
Lawrence Pugh is vogue's winter 2023
cover star the actress opened up about
her former relationship with actor Zach
Braff saying we weren't in anyone's
faces it was just that people didn't
like it they imagined me with someone
younger and someone in Blockbusters and
she brought back a special edition of
cooking with Flo for Vogue preparing
garlic crostine hey this is cooking with
clubs
I always like making a few mistakes
because to me that's where the best food
and cooking comes from so for example
today I don't really know what
temperature to put the oven on
[Music]